hi I'm Dalia and most hated lesbian in
Egypt
[Music]
the post was me saying that my dad
congratulated me for my relationship and
that I can't believe that he did that I
was so happy about it I wrote it in both
Arabic and English and that was it until
yeah until I until people so my post and
things went crazy I was attacked by
people like on messages and posts and my
dad got death threats and and other
hateful messages and then I posted my
response
some people said how how come her dad
actually supported her for being in a
relationship with a woman some people
were really upset and mad about me
saying that in public some people said
that I'm gonna be cursed and they are
not supposed to respect me since God has
cursed me already and got one forgive me
others said that I should be stoned
yeah that's you and I should be killed
me and my dad even tap Lloyd newspapers
they just wrote random information about
me that I grew up in Europe like some
fools information about me I received a
lot of messages that are supportive
telling me that I should continue some
people told me like just be happy you
don't need to bother yourself with what
people say about you I mean I was really
in need for for this support I would say
to the queer youth in the Middle East
and North Africa that coming out is not
the only way to do it you need to find
your supportive circle if not try to
find people that you can relate to on
the Internet stay strong and think
positively because there are people out
there who would support you and be there
for you
so that what I would say
[Music]